Leadership is 1 process,
not 1 function 1 leader does not necessarily occupy 1 management position
1 good leadership involves properly key skills so that the
company reaches its maximum potential
But these skills are learned.
This course discusses specific strategies to hone your leadership skills.
There are different key skills and practices
that can be divided into 4 categories,
self-awareness,
relational capacity,
business sense,
organizational strategy.
..
All these skills are based on your integrity.
The main thing is to be 1 trusted person who conforms to his or her values
in an ethical manner 1 good reputation is at the heart of leadership.
The 1st aspect,
self-awareness implies knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and the image you send back.
This skill is the foundation on which all others will rest.
For example,
how do you manage your emotions during stress?
What do your latest evaluations show?
Does your supervisor's perception of your performance match yours?
Relationship skills cover all aspects of your working relationships
with your senior and subordinate colleagues In your interactions,
how well do you understand?
Quickly connect with others through personal interactions Can
you interpret the emotions behind actions and words?
Business acumen covers technical skills,
decision making,
management and knowledge of your industry Technical skills depend
on your job If you work in finance,
you need to master the audit process If you work in industry,
you know how to run 1 machine.
Organizational strategy is to move your business
forward by analyzing your industry,
setting a strategic direction,
and driving innovation Can you identify and work with people who play
a key role in achieving your goals Frequently consult the national
and international press to identify issues that may affect your company.
Its skills are important to every company and every position,
whether you are a novice in the field or CEO of a multinational company,
the more your responsibilities increase,
the more complex and nuanced the skills of each category become
Evaluate your skills or leadership in each category.
With the exercise files you will be able to
identify the skills to be preferred,
knowing that you will develop the other ingredients.